let's have a little bit of a review of
what a function is before we talk about
what it means it what what the domain of
a function means so a function we can
view as something so I'll put a function
in this box here and it takes inputs and
for a given input it's going to produce
an output which we call f of X so for
example let's say that we have the
function let's say we have the function
f of X is equal to 2 over X so in this
case if so let me see so if that's my
function f if I were to input the number
3 well f of 3 that we're going to output
we have we know how to figure that out
we've defined it right over here it's
going to be equal to 2 over 3 it's going
to be equal to 2 over 3 so we were able
to for that input we're able to find an
output if our input was PI then we input
into our function and then F of Pi when
when X is PI we're going to output f of
Pi which is equal to 2 over PI so we
could write this as 2 over 5 so we were
able to find the output pretty easily
but now let's do something interesting
let's attempt to input 0 into the
function if we input 0 does the function
tell us what we need to output does this
definition tell us what we need to
output so if I attempt to put x equals 0
then this definition would say f of 0
would be 2 over 0 but 2 over 0 is
undefined let me write this 2 over 0
this is undefined this function
definition does not tell us what to
actually do with 0 it gives us an
undefined answer so this function is not
defined here it gives a question mark so
this gets to the essence of what domain
is domain is the set of all inputs over
which the function is defined so the
domain of this function f would be all
real numbers except for x equals 0 so
let me write down these big ideas this
is the domain a domain of a function
actually my write that out domain of a
function a domain of a function is
set of all inputs inputs over which the
function is defined over which the
function is defined or the function has
defined outputs over which the function
has defined outputs so the domain for
this F in particular so the domain for
this one if I wanted to say its domain I
could say look it's going to be the set
of this curly brackets these are kind of
typical mathy set notation I can say
okay is going to be the set of and I'm
going to put curly brackets like that
well X can be a member this is this
little this little symbol means a member
of the real numbers but it can't just be
any real number can be most of the real
numbers except it cannot be zero because
we don't know this definition it's
undefined when you put it in put a zero
so X is a member of the real numbers and
we write real numbers we write it with
this kind of double stroke right over
here that's the set of all real numbers
such that but we have to we have to put
it up put the exception zero is not a x
equals zero is not a member of that
domain such that X does not does not
equal zero now let's let's make this a
little bit more concrete by doing some
more examples so more examples we do
hopefully the clearer this will become
so let's say we have another function
and just be clear when at all we don't
always have to use F F sin X's we could
say let's say we have G of Y is equal to
the square root of Y minus six so what's
the domain here what is the set of all
inputs over which this function G is
defined so here we are inputting a Y
into function G and we're going to
output G of Y well it's going to be
defined as long as whatever we have
under the radical right over here is
non-negative if this becomes negative
are our traditional principal root
operator here is not defined we need
something that if we if this ended up
being a negative number all right well
how you take the principal root of a
negative number and we're just saying
this is kind of the traditional
principal root up
Reiter so y minus six Y minus six needs
to be greater than or equal to zero in
order for in order for G to be defined
for that input Y or you could say add
six to both sides Y needs to be greater
than or equal to six or you can say G is
defined for any inputs Y that are
greater than or equal to six so we could
say the domain here we could say the
domain here is the set of all Y's that
are a member of the real numbers such
that Y such that they're also greater
than or equal such that they're also
greater than or equal to six so
hopefully this is starting to make some
sense and you know we're also always
used to functions defined this way but
you could even see functions that are
defined in fairly exotic ways you could
see a function let me say H of X H of X
could be defined as it literally could
be defined as well H of X is going to be
one if X is equal to PI and it's equal
to 0 if if X is equal to 3 now what's
the domain here and I encourage you to
pause the video and think about it well
this function is actually only defined
for two inputs if you we know H of we
know H of Pi if you input PI into it we
know you're going to output 1 and we
know that if you input 3 into it H of 3
when x equals 3 you're going to you're
going to put some commas here you're
going to get a 0 but if you input
anything else what's H of 4 going to be
well it hasn't defined it it's undefined
what's H of negative 1 going to be it
hasn't defined it so the domain the
domain here the domain of H is literally
its it's just literally going to be the
the two valid inputs that X can be are 3
and PI 3 and by these are the only valid
inputs these are the only two numbers
over which this function is actually
defined so this hopefully starts to give
you a flavor of of why we care about
domains not all functions are defined
over all real numbers some are defined
for only a small subset of real numbers
or for some other thing or only whole
numbers or natural numbers or positive
numbers
negative numbers or they have exceptions
so we'll see that as we do more and more
examples